as we head into the holiday weekend many
are getting their fireworks ready some
have already started setting them off
but it's really important to keep your
celebrations safe sasha loftis joining
us with a warning from someone who dealt
with a pretty scary situation last year
sasha denise and brian fireworks are fun
but they can turn dangerous quickly
especially if you have trees or bushes
in your front yard i spoke with one man
who had a scare last year and is
encouraging everyone to stay safe
we all know the sound
fireworks exploding across southern
nevada for the fourth of july that's
just a big boom but they can be
dangerous leonel aguirre says this tree
in his front yard caught fire last year
we ended up just running i ended up just
getting the hose because i thought it
was this tree right behind me that was
on fire he believes the flames were
sparked by illegal fireworks these are
defined as any explosives that shoot
high into the air it's already a busy
night and it's going to be even busier
if we continue with illegal fireworks
clark county fire inspector martin
casilla says his team will be out all
weekend looking for anyone breaking the
law with the ulighted we ride it
campaign remember
there's been fires caused by illegal
fireworks every year we have a house
fire every year there is an injury
caused by that if you're caught you
could face a hefty fine between 500 and
10 thousand dollars it's just scary to
have someone just set up a fire in the
middle of the street after last year's
scare leonel encourages others to stick
to what's allowed we have to make sure
that we
you know celebrate with carefulness with
precautions so everyone can enjoy the
holiday weekend safely
if you see or suspect illegal fireworks
in your neighborhood do not call 9-1-1
unless it's an emergency you can report
them online we have a link on our
website 8newsnow.com